foreign
do y'all want to know what my favorite
word is
the f word
some people think it's a little dirty
others really like to throw it around
oh y'all thought I meant
no no no no no no my favorite word is
fandom
this talk is about fandom and now fandom
can enrich your life and build a
community of people that you might not
have always talked to
right but I'm sure when y'all think of
fandom
y'all think
nerds and cosplay and fan fiction and
neck beards and people in dark basements
and stuff and all that is true
but you also probably think about
America's ass
I do
[Applause]
and yes fandom is all of this stuff
but it is actually a a community of
people that share a passion
fandom is a community of people that
share a passion
right but like all things there's a
there's a spectrum right you got your
casual fans
your fans
your hardcore fans and then you have
your fanatics
and they can get really ugly
just like that ugly thing every time I
see it I run scared sorry to all my
Phillies fans it's ugly
right
but I want to talk about the difference
between being a fan and being a fanatic
right I'm a street fighter
um fans
want to bring in Joy they want to share
stuff as much as possible with you right
Fanatics are and I know I watched uh
Obi-Wan last night so Star Wars was on
the brain
uh but Fanatics are those Star Wars fans
that chase two grown women off of the
internet because they gave the
Millennium Falcon to a girl right they
weren't happy about that those are
fanatics
we want to be fans we don't want to be
right because fans create worlds
once the story is over once the movie is
done they want to keep it going so they
start to create
cosplay fan fiction video games
I mean I myself have a lot of feelings
and fandoms so I have a newsletter that
I write whenever I remember to write it
and also and because I'm because we're
friends here I cosplay
I'm not new to this I'm True to this
right I wanted to still still engage
with with all of the worlds that I love
even though the movie was over
fans aren't Gatekeepers
y'all can clap
right we all have that friend that
watches us watch a movie because they
want us to like the same part that they
like
that is a fan Fanatics are those people
who quiz me when I come into a comic
book store thinking because I look like
this that I can't know about
comics
right
and fans learn life lessons from some of
the nerdiest places
right so for
a quick example how many Blazers fans
are here
right
y'all are really patient people I'm sure
y'all will continue to be patient
with that number seven pick y'all guys
sucks we go
[Applause]
or if you are in Oregon women's Ducks
fan which we all should be
probably understand the importance of
women in power the value of women in
sports
uh and you're probably just overall a
much better person
[Applause]
because fandom wind harness is greater
than any box office number
right fandom wind hardness is greater
you meet people who you might have not
necessarily always talked to right you
learn from so many different people and
you learn a lot of things from these
things that you love so much whether or
not you
realize it right think about what you
put on your locker when you were a
teenager or in your or in your three
ring binder or even on even on your
phone background right now
right something somewhere has inspired
you or guided you along this journey
called life
right so I'm gonna give y'all
10 10 Things I have a lot of fandoms I
have a lot of them but I'm giving you 10
things that my fandoms have taught me
number one
Storm from the X-Men y'all should be
clapping right now
[Music]
she is the leader of the X-Men as a
young black girl seeing this tall
beautiful black woman with all this
white hair and that very operated voice
leading the way
was very impactful for you know a fox
kids Saturday morning
that's my son
um
Star Wars taught me that my world can be
as big as a galaxy far far away whether
whether that is real or or fake my world
could be much bigger than just you know
the six blocks that I call my home
Wonder Woman
taught me that my body at any sculpt at
any shape is is beautiful right Wonder
Woman spent her entire life y'all
Wonder Woman spent her entire life
training for battle she was not going to
be a size zero she was going to have
quadriceps and deltoids I learned that
word a couple weeks ago deltoid
um
right and she was going to look strong
and look and look beautiful while doing
it
all right my fourth one
[Music]
Venus and Serena as any black girl
specifically we were forced to watch
them whether or not we'd like tennis or
not
[Music]
also because it came on cable so you
didn't have to like look for it
um
but my North Star as a big sister has
always been these two because when the
world was against them they always had
each other
so whether or not I am being a good
sister in the moment that is what I
always look towards
uh all right sneakers taught me the
importance of quality and detail and
nerds sneaker heads you all are nerds
nobody cares about quality of leather
from 1987 to 2022 except y'all y'all
need to just accept it
Harry Potter fan fiction
taught me that I could write write
myself into any story right those books
about this big and uh black people had
about what eight words
so I wanted to fill in those gaps and I
was very good at it too I also wrote
some smut you can look for that later
Sailor Moon
taught me the power of female
friendships
that's it
[Applause]
um and Luke now this isn't really a
lesson but my father is a massive nerd
and he would see me going on to these
superheroes storm blah blah and he would
be like well what about Black Panther
what about Luke Cage what about Misty
Knight and in doing that he was trying
to teach me yes you can love everything
that is current but you have to know
about your past and so showing me all of
these black superheroes from the 70s
from from the 60s kind of led me through
life and down when they're here talking
to y'all that's here so blame him
boy bands
B2K specifically taught me to scream
really loud
in China
taught me that I can be the ninth wonder
of the world that I can stand in a ring
or an office room or here on this red
carpet and
take commands right because in a lot of
rooms I would probably be the only woman
I will probably be the only black person
I'm for damn sure probably gonna be the
only black woman so people are going to
look at me anyway I should have
something to say I should be able to
take it take to this thing
[Music]
so listen don't be don't be afraid of
the of the f word because when you love
what you love out loud that is audacious
when you love what you love un
unapologetically it is beautiful all
right so it y'all be a fan
thank you